so as Binyam prepared for this what do
you mean for having a baby again yes
again you heard her right she said again
Ariela revealed some major news about
Binyam and his American ex-wife yeah
sign has this strict traditional Muslim
family who is pushing me super hard to
get married right away so I'm really
being crazy right now meanwhile bring me
is eager to head off to Jordan
but her dad struggles as he tries to
hide his pain behind that smile I don't
want to be a big girl like I always am I
don't know if I'm gonna be a big boy are
you gonna cry I'm fat summit has a
heart-to-heart with his brother about
Ginny's age the number is double the new
age Jimmy is the same age of your mom
right yeah actually jenny is elder than
my mom is and that's the thing my
opinions doesn't like in it and Devin is
moving back to South Korea with hopes
that this time Ji Hoon will keep his
promise and provide for their family
it's your turn to take on that
responsibility so I can stay at home and
take care of the kids cuz my body buddy
hey my 90 day fans fam it's Malizia here
let's go ahead and get into the must-see
moments from the latest episode of the
other way kicking things off with
Ariella who were built that Binyam has
an American ex-wife and a son baby was
previously married to an American woman
and our stories there are some
similarities she also got pregnant early
on in their relationship
how old is Binyam child
I don't know the specifics about why
William and his ex-wife divorced I do
know that they are not on speaking terms
she returned to the US with their son
and he hasn't seen his son face to face
since that's concerning that would
definitely be something I personally
would have to know like why did you get
a whole divorce and why did this woman
get so mad that she decided to take your
son away and she hasn't reached out to
you since I just think those are things
you should know and if you don't know
them it's somewhat like pulling the wool
over your own eye and the similarities
between these two stories just makes you
hold your breath Abed
I tried it with Ariela back in May and
she talks about the first time she and
Bingham actually started spending time
together
she mentioned that he laid it on her he
said hey I want a baby I want a wife and
I want a good job and at first she
thought that that was a bit too much a
bit forward she told him to calm down
but now after learning this information
it just has sparks all of these theories
in my mind and of course I could be
wrong but I also could be right so
before I tell you my theories I just
want to mention this my first theory
comes from my heart okay
in the second theory it's coming from
here it's coming from my mind
okay so theory number one Binyam just
has a thing for American women you know
the last situation didn't work out well
and he wants to create this situation
again theory number two Vivian's on a
mission I'm not sure what that mission
is but just like areolas family could
not hide their concern
I can't hide mine either during my chat
with areolas she also shared a message
for ninety-day fans who might criticize
her relationship I think that the best
the best thing I can say to that is you
know well one thing the first thing I'll
say is
I got a baby boy out of it so it didn't
go too bad but the other thing I'll say
that you know in relationships whether
you end up with the person forever or
not you definitely learn something from
them and you you know you grow as a
person and you learn something about
yourself so I don't think that uh it's a
it's a loss either way that's all I'll
say hey if she's not concerned about it
I guess we shouldn't be either right
next up summit reveals that he is
willing to let go of his relationship
with his family to be with Ginny cause
I'm happy I don't want to pick them
happy and make me suffer once again
which I did before
I agree I want them to support me I want
them to like understand why I am loving
Jenny and if they don't want to accept
her then it's okay don't be a part of my
lack of my life they can just mind their
own business he is serious summit is in
a really tough position right now he is
literally going against centuries of
tradition by deciding not to continue to
be in his arranged marriage and on top
of that Ginny is three decades older
than him
I feel like traditions should be
respected in some cases it's a great way
to learn discipline but I also feel like
if it hinders your happiness or it
doesn't attribute to you feeling like
your best self
what are you staying in it for is it to
please other people
and if so that's just no way to live
summit claims that he was miserable in
his arranged marriage but he did it for
his family and it didn't work out and
now he's choosing to live for him I know
this might sound cliche but whether we
believe it or not love is blind love
doesn't discriminate between age gender
or race when you feel it you feel it and
it happens whether we understand it or
not
finally ji-hoon promises Devon that he
has a job but there's just one problem
he doesn't know how much he makes so far
I've been the one financially supporting
everything and working and it's your
turn to take on that responsibility so I
can stay at home and take care of the
kids because body body body
don't worry I I got a new job
what what is your new job hi
[Music]
how much does it pay
Devin deserves an award for her level of
patience because ji-hoon is having this
conversation like he could care less she
is flying around the world for a second
time to accommodate him and based off of
a sneak preview he admits that he really
doesn't have a real job and that he's
been lying to Devin so during this
episode there is a clip where Ji Hoon is
getting his hair cut by this barber and
the barber read Ji Hoon like literally
read him the barber said that he's a
fortune-teller and he's been reading
people's faces for years and he told Ji
Hoon that Ji hoons basically stubborn
and he doesn't like hard work
shiitake talons on their own budget
al-bari couldn't answer though I'm dry
oh I need to find this barber Ji Hoon
knows he needs to change it's just a
matter of how long Devin is gonna wait
next week on 90 day the other way for
the first time in 3 years
Armando sits down with his family to
talk about his sexuality I'm very scared
Ginny touches down in India without any
receipts of summits divorce
no more lying and something goes down
when Brittany makes it to Jordan I'm
American I have my own culture when you
go with your people you do it your whole
get an out of my face tell us tell us
well a whole lot to keep up with there
but don't worry
here at ET we are covering it all all
right my 90 day ban spam Wow
see you next time
[Music]